Reggie Miller joining us on the program
how you feelin reg I feel great but I do
have to say this in just in terms of
basketball all right what a season of
disappointment
obviously LeBron joining the Lakers we
had high expectations personally I think
you and I we've talked about this we
didn't expect him to win a championship
this year but we certainly didn't think
they were not going to make the playoffs
yeah so a huge disappointment and then
last night
you know Zion Williamson do Coach K RJ
Barrett cam reddish I think most of us
had them certainly in the final floor
and a lot of people's bracket probably
have been busted with Duke losing to
Michigan State just in terms of
basketball a season of disappointment in
my eyes all right that play that was
drawn up by Coach K I'm assuming they
drew up a play for RJ Barrett and I
guess to most people surprised it didn't
go to Zion Williamson we have the
benefit of hindsight here but did it
make more sense going to RJ Barrett a
more pure scorer than Zion as opposed to
Zion just making something happen
well the way Zion had it going I would
have put the ball in his hands for him
to make a play if you remember it was RJ
Barrett's three that tied the ballgame
well how did he get that three the ball
was in Zion Williamson's hand and the
defense tilted and shifted toward Zion
as he made that move they over helped
they overplayed and Barrett got that
three so not necessarily you have to put
the ball in Zion Williamson's hand for
him to score but I would have put it in
his hands for him to make a play
rather than scoring or assisting and
finding one of his teammates again you
and I we can play Monday Morning
Quarterback which actually we are doing
literally but it's hard for us to
question Coach K they were in the moment
living in the moment and he felt that
that was the the correct situation for
RJ to be and but per
I would have put the ball in Zion Zions
hands and allowed him to create a player
rather for himself or forced teammate
can you think of somebody more exciting
for one year than jaian Williamson in
college basketball in today's age of
YouTube Instagram like Twitter no he
came with a built-in package he came you
know he's a YouTube generation type
player and we've all seen the dunks from
his a EU circuit from his club teams
high school so that was built in and
traveling with him to to Duke so no for
one year the hype how about this he's
lived up to the hype now I will say this
there was so much hype behind LeBron
James coming out of high school and he
has lived up to the height you know
being on the cover of Sports Illustrated
and all that but social media wasn't
around like this for King James
so no for one year for a high school
player to be this dominant because to me
he was the player of the year in college
basketball as a true freshman the hype
was real and he lived up to the hype is
he the best player in the most exciting
well okay the best player in Duke
history no now if he stayed another two
or three years possibly but that goes
too late of course that goes to Laettner
then you've got to throw Hurley Grant
Hill Elton Brand
I mean JJ reddick there's a list of
unbelievable college Duke players that
have put up fabulous number J Wayne the
most exciting oh yeah J William any look
if he would have stayed a couple more
years he probably would have been
probably would have surpassed Laettner
but it's hard for me to leap have his
eye on leapfrog all those people we just
mentioned for one season is either the
most hyped in the most exciting out of
all those players that we just mentioned
absolutely the most athletic absolutely
but he can't be the best player in Duke
history no he's the most exciting but I
think Grant Hill is the the best player
best you know basketball Christian
Laettner is the most accomplished Grant
Hill so what's the criteria are you just
going Khalid are you throwing it are you
throwing in the NBA no no no no no I
mean if I throw in the NBA then Grant
Hill is certainly better than Christian
Laettner
correct you're talking about college
career
no one will supplant Christian Laettner
no but this is about athleticism this is
the best the most talented player Duke
in history I would probably go with
grant first and then probably Zion okay
if you could place Zion right now in the
NBA for his own good
do you want to put him in Cleveland
Phoenix
New York or Chicago I would probably put
him in Phoenix out of all those places
the infrastructure is there you've got
an up-and-coming superstar in Devin
Booker just the stability at head coach
is there other places you mentioned New
York LA Cleveland there's so much drama
in those organizations I know there's
two of the three are major markets but
as much as I love LeBron and everything
that's going on with Luke Walton which
to me is not fair there's so much
expectations of drama the surrounding
with the Lakers right now but it is a
storied franchise along with the Knicks
the Knicks I'm stuck for the last 15 20
years I absolutely want to put him in
New York but I would put him in Phoenix
because you've got DeAndre Aiden a big
man so the infrastructure is there for
him to succeed I think he would be great
in the Valley of the Sun they play an
up-tempo style which fits it fits his
game I think he can plug him right in at
that small forward power forward
position and I think he would fit in
great with Booker
natan so Phoenix would be my first
choice if you're in terms of
infrastructure if you're going for hype
and flair I would go with either Coast
Lakers or New York I wouldn't put him in
Cleveland they look they've been
fortunate to get LeBron and Kyrie Irving
and um Olympics they don't they don't
deserve another number one pick I'm
sorry they don't
Paul Pierce came out and said Zions one
of the top 50 players right now in
basketball NBA this time the truth is
not correct come on I mean he's good but
what he was doing as a freshman he was
playing bully ball I mean he was bigger
and stronger than a lot of a lot of
upperclassmen
in the college game he won't be able to
play volleyball at the pro level so he's
going to have to define his game we did
see a couple of jump shots a couple
threes in their game versus Michigan
State but that has to be a consistent
thing athleticism is off the chart I get
that but we've got guys in the in the G
League that are athletic they can't make
that next leap into the NBA so I get the
athleticism and I get the dunk but now
it's time for him to define his game get
in the lab find a coach Hellenic trainer
he's got to shave off some weight he
does have to lose weight and he's got to
get a consistent jump shot we do that we
do have players in the NBA that have
been all stars without jump shots and we
may have one that could be an MVP this
season and on T takubo and Ben Simmons
comes to mind as an all-star but Zion is
much more athletic in my opinion and
those two guys the Greek freak is
different because of his length but he
he's got to get a jump shot so I'm not
going to put him in the top 50 right now
but maybe 51 how about Reggie Miller
Hall of Famer he's on the call for the
Warriors and the Lakers tonight okay
when you when you see this game on the
schedule at the beginning of the year
we're sweaty I'm like this is going to
be great because we got LeBron James
versus draymond Green and curry and
Katie what uh okay and how much time do
you spend on the negativity like looking
at the Lakers for whatever this was this
season and then how do you fix that how
much part of this game on Thursday will
you spend with the Lakers coaching free
agents LeBron turning 35 you know where
this franchise is headed I will that
will probably the early talking points I
would say first quarter talking points
while people are still tuned in yeah but
the rest of the three quarters will be
all about the Warriors and them going
for a three-peat where the story should
be then focusing on you know getting
that number one seed because there's a
dogfight right now with the Nuggets for
that number one seed out west which
personally I don't think they really
care about that because they feel that
there's a better team and they can go
into Mile High and win one or two games
so they're not really focused in on that
but I think their quest for a three-peat
that's what quarters two three or four
will be all about the Warriors it's easy
to jump on the Lakers and say what if
and LeBron this and Luke Walton Matt and
magic and palinka I get it
those are for first quarter you know
talking points but it this story is not
about this game and story is not about
the Lakers it's sad but it's all about
the Warriors in a quest for a three-peat
that's the bigger picture in my opinion
if Luke Waltons fired is that job a
coveted job absolutely
you've got LeBron James a top-five
player of all time in my opinion and the
potential of getting another superstar
absolutely but the grass is not always
greener
yeah but red you get blamed if it goes
bad
you know it's better if you do you do
yes but that goes with it I mean you
don't get any credit tyloo took over for
David Blatt you want a championship and
I mean even though he got fired later
yeah but that comes with the territory
that comes with coaching the King and I
don't know if it's a coveted job I don't
covered it's the Lakers I know with you
championship it's the Lakers yes its
coveted yeah oh you'll hear tyloo you'll
hear Barr Jackson you'll hear Jason Kidd
so yeah you'll hear all these guys names
I'm sure one of the Van Gundy if not
both will be mentioned everyone will
line up to to be in line to be coached
by two coats be coached by yeah who's
coaching who yeah I don't know I it's
not right though it's not right if Luke
Walton gets fired because they didn't
give Byron Scott the long leash even
though they told him he was gonna
develop the young players and he got the
boot and then the same thing with Luke
you know he develops these young guys
and then you know the magic goes out and
gets LeBron and then now all of a sudden
he can't coach it's ridiculous
I don't think it would be fair to fire
Luke Walton but on the other hand I know
it's a business yeah but if LeBron says
hey he's not getting fired then he's not
getting fired he's not he's not going to
but yeah yeah I'm moving moving into a
new man cave here in a couple of weeks
yeah yeah I didn't run it by you sorry
where's the man cave going to be located
and am I invited a couple of miles from
here oh well do you need some help
decorating like moving you know some of
the memorabilia over I mean I would love
for you to take the first three in the
building but I don't know if that's
going to be possible
I gotta make a visit I gotta make a
visit when I'm out I wanna okay
all righty really you're gonna you're
gonna love you're gonna love this
okay just letting you know it's gonna be
crazy yeah this man cave is awesome but
this next man cave
ridiculous yeah yeah I think I've
outdone myself yeah congratulations yeah
yeah it'll be great so we have the
Reggie Miller autographed basketball in
the Reggie Miller autographed jersey
that we'll be making the trip over to
the man cave and soon to be a Reggie
Miller three-point boom baby on site
whenever that will be I'm coming in to
lay some threes and bring a ping-pong
table in there too I ate a Cal Poly I am
getting a ping-pong table - okay all
right I got a rose I got all set up I
have fun with the Lakers in the Warriors
red where is Lonzo ball he got a he
sprained his ankle in January
he's probably meeting with a lawyer so
we're talking about baller brown shoes
and recouping some money and what he's
probably doing yeah yeah boy didn't see
that one coming
I thought big baller by Nike you know
that's that sounds successfully reg will
be on the call with Kevin Harlan
Thursday night he will sell the laws and
the Warriors is only thank you right you
Aloysius Miller jr. the third for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]